Bonjour à toutes et à tous
Et surtout à toi, Olivier,
qui devrais apprécier cet épisode.
Lui...
C'est Hemigrammus Bleheri...
ou Nez Rouge de son petit nom.
C'est un poisson originaire d'Amazonie.
Un poisson d'eau douce qui...
a le nez rouge.
Et figurez-vous que c'est une star
chez les chercheurs.
Si c'est une star c'est parce
qu'il est connu pour se déplacer
avec ses congénères en grands bancs de poissons.
Et surtout il adore nager à contre courant.
Et le nom scientifique pour cette habitude, c'est la rhéotaxie.
Et c'est le même mot qu'on utilise pour les spermatozoïdes.
Bon
Imaginez un banc de poissons nageant face au courant.
A votre avis, dans l'eau, ça va prendre quelle forme ?
Moi, instinctivement je vais plutôt penser
à une formation en triangle...
ou en diamant.
Un peu comme les escadrilles d'avions 14 juillet...
ou les oiseaux migrateurs.
Un truc bien aérodynamique, quoi !
Il se trouve que la rhéotaxie est
un sujet très étudié en hydrodynamique.
Les modèles...
et les expériences se basent sur le calcul des tourbillons créés par chaque poisson.
L'idée est que lorsqu'un poisson nage, sa queue
va créer des tourbillons dans l'eau environnante.
Et ces tourbillons vont affecter la nage
de ses plus proches voisins.
Ces modèles, qui sont en deux dimensions,
montrent que la configuration qui garantit
la plus faible dépense en énergie des poissons
est celle dite en diamant.
Bon ! C'est plus ou moins conforme
à ce que j'imaginais.
Tout va bien.
Une équipe de chercheurs de Paris
a voulu tester ces résultats expérimentalement
et en trois dimensions.
Ils ont mis les petits Nez Rouges dans un tunnel d'eau,
dans lequel circule un courant
dont ils peuvent contrôler la vitesse.
Ce qu'il y a de bien avec les Nez Rouges c'est que...
comme ils nagent à contre-courant,
ils vont adapter leur vitesse,
à la vitesse du courant qu'on leur impose.
Donc on peut savoir exactement à quelle
vitesse ils nagent.
Et pour la petite histoire, les chercheurs mesurent
cette vitesse en longueur de poisson / seconde.
Ici par exemple : 0,8 longueur de poisson / seconde.
A l'aide de caméras rapides placées
au dessus et sur les côtés du tunnel,
ils ont pu étudier individuellement et en 3d,
la position de chacun des poissons du groupe.
Et ils ont mesuré l'amplitude et la fréquence
des battements de leur queue.
En fait le mouvement de la queue est
un indicateur de l'énergie dépensée par le poisson.
Oui ! Quand on remue la queue moins vite,
on dépense moins d'énergie.
C'est logique.
A faible vitesse, les chercheurs observent que les poissons adoptent, comme prévu,
une configuration en diamant.
Mais quand la vitesse du courant augmente,
la configuration du banc change.
Et ils adoptent une configuration en phalanx.
Petit point culture :
Phalanx en grec ancien,
phalange en français,
est une formation militaire,
en lignes compactes de lanciers lourdement armés, conçue pour anéantir l'infanterie ennemie.
FOOORRR-MATIONNNN
PHALANX !
Et là, vous vous dites sûrement comme moi :
Mais  pourquoi ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans leur petite tête rouge ?
Contre toute attente,
quand le courant augmente,
autour de quatre longueurs de poisson / seconde,
le banc se réorganise en une ligne compacte,
au sein de laquelle le mouvement
de chacun des poissons
est synchrone avec celui de ses voisins.
En fait, plus le courant augmente,
plus l'effort à fournir pour maintenir
la vitesse de nage devient intense.
Et c'est à ce moment-là,
que les poissons se mettent en formation phalenx.
Les chercheurs ont remarqué
qu'en se positionnant ainsi,
la fréquence de battement
des queues des poissons diminue.
Ce qui veut dire que cette configuration paraît particulièrement économe en énergie.
L'efficacité de la nage dans cette configuration
est intimement liée à la synchronisation du mouvement
de la queue de chaque poisson
avec ses plus proches voisins.
Ainsi le mouvement de l'eau déplacée par la queue de chaque poisson
a un effet positif sur le corps
de ses plus proches voisins
qui fournissent alors moins d'énergie
pour déplacer leur propre queue.
Les chercheurs souhaitent maintenant
modéliser en trois dimensions,
l'écoulement de l'eau, lors de la nage
des nez rouges au sein d'un banc.
Et leurs résultats pourraient inspirer la
conception de petits robots nageurs...
bio-inspirés.
Voilà ! Je vous rappelle que vous pouvez trouver
les sources de toutes ces études dans la description.
Moi je vais partir...
avec Rodolphe.
Et je vous laisse sur cette fin d'épisode...
en queue de poisson.
Hey !
Psit !
Et n'oublie pas...
Abonne-toi !